it is a little cold I mean maybe my
thin-skinned living in Vegas is getting
to me and while they may have been
chilly during our interview the Scott
brothers have nothing but warmth in
their hearts this holiday season they
are giving back to some very deserving
families who were still struggling with
the devastation caused by Hurricane
Katrina we always like to give back so
we found these stories in New Orleans
where there's 16,000 homes that are
still unlivable from Katrina which was
11 years ago I'm willing to put out the
effort and get into it this this one
house we came across it had mold rot it
had you know carpenter ants everything
you could possibly throw at this house
that had problems with so we went in
there whipped it into shape and now this
homeowner who has not been in her home
for 11 years is back home and although
audiences won't get to meet the
recipient on brothers take New Orleans
both Jonathan and drew were truly
touched by her and her family's response
to the renovation shooting New Orleans
it wasn't just renovating this house we
were really changing lives we're
renovating their lives these are
families have been out of their houses
for so long and to see the emotional
response when we revealed the house to
them in the end it meant everything to
us I mean we were tearing up